hello everyone and welcome to one of the
greatest chess games ever played uh
pretty much if you ever picked up a
chess book this game was in it along
with maybe morphy's opera house game or
anderson's immortal game or his
evergreen game or just you know uh
it's the the game that basically defines
chess and what's interesting about this
one is that it's uh according to mikhail
botwinick the the former world champion
it is the first game played in modern
style so uh he describes this as modern
attacking chess now for those of you who
have been subscribed to the channel or
just have been following the channel for
more than five years you probably know
that i have covered this game in 2017
but now we're gonna take a look at the
game through a more of a modern lens and
also the videos are now of course uh in
60 frames per second uh and we're gonna
enjoy a few few lines more and we're
gonna discuss a little bit more uh so
the game was played in 1907 uh in lords
in poland uh and it was played in a
tournament akiba rubinstein won first
place in the tournament but
this game is basically anyone uh
remembers from uh from that tournament
and for very good reason so let's check
out the game and then we're going to
discuss a bit more uh not just about the
game but also about the tournament and
his opponent uh gershorot levy uh also a
polish master uh sometimes he is he can
be found in literature as georg but i
think gersh is is a more more proper uh
that being said let's check out the game
as it's uh really an incredible one the
game was played on uh supposedly on 26th
of december so it's uh kind of a
christmas miracle game uh but uh you'll
see what i mean by this uh so uh gersh
rotlavi has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 we have d5 by rubenstein
knight to f3 and now e6 with uh e3 and
now c5 so uh that's what variation uh we
have c4 and knight to c6 the players are
now bringing all of their knights into
the game knight c3 knight to f6 and now
this is a position that can be found in
modern chess it's nothing that
has gone out of date or anything here a3
is the most popular move but the game uh
the move that's played in this game the
captures on c5 is the second most
popular move uh even in 2022 now so uh
these uh gentlemen are playing a very
very good chest so bishop captures on c5
a3 now preparing to kick away the bishop
with b4 we have a6 b4 chasing away the
bishop and bishop to d6 we have bishop
to b2 and now uh rubinstein just castles
and here we have a move that has never
been uh played after this game uh
happened and that is queen to the two
now uh rotlavi uh
took a lot of uh beating for this move
as of course uh if he won the game you
know everyone would say it's a good move
but since he lost the game in the way
that he did uh everyone was you know uh
as they say a general after the battle
and they deemed it the move that it's
completely uh you know not in the in the
spirit of the position that black can
just move the queen put the rook on the
d file open up the d file the rook then
faces the queen and that the queen does
not belong on d2 better would be queen
seat or maybe queen to e2
but modern engines actually say that uh
rotlavis move is perfectly fine and that
you can definitely play like this
however after this game in 1907 it has
never been repeated again and while you
could now for example uh just play
something like the captures on c4
rook to d1 is very nice for white we
attacked the bishop and there's no way
to add more defenders to the bishop so
we would have to move it and then we
just claim the pawn back offer a queen
trade and everything is perfectly fine
however in the game rubinstein did not
go for this he played queen to e7 uh and
now uh white needs to continue in the
modern style however here is where roth
levy takes a wrong turn here you should
capture on d5 definitely and after he
captures you're going to capture with
the knight captures captures and
captures and the rubinstein would have a
couple of very good options like a5 you
could also play rook 38 to threaten some
nasty discoveries you could play bishop
to e6 to challenge the queen so it's a
perfectly fine position for both white
and black uh but after queen to e7 uh
rotlavis played bishop to d3 and this
gives rubinstein just a little bit too
much because now he captures on c4
forces rotlev to waste the tempo bishop
captures on c4 we have b5 now again uh
he creates uh this b7 square for his
light square bishop to be developed
everything with tempo as the bishop is
attacked again bishop back to d3 and now
rook to d8 and now okay now you
definitely could say that the queen does
not belong on d2 and i'm sure the
masters of that era uh had this position
in mind where when they were you know uh
beating him up after the game uh but
okay now he plays queen to e2 as the
queen really does not belong on a d file
now and bishop to b7 uh so uh you can
see now that uh rubinstein's bishop's
pair is definitely fully operational but
also rotlavis bishop's pair is fully
operational so it's not a it's not a bad
bishop there uh here we have castles by
rocletti and now knight to e5 this is
where rubenstein uh really uh kicks it
up a notch he plays knight to the e5 and
now he opens up his light square bishop
knight captures an e5 bishop captures an
e5 and here uh you are threatening uh
well
a a a lot of really cool moves with uh
with black here uh just you know the
simple bishop captures king captures
queen to d6 check and pick up the bishop
or even if something like rook 8 the c1
is played we can even play rook captures
on d3 and this will allow rubenstein to
have a devastating attack uh let's say
queen captures on the 3 now knight g4
and everything is attacked h3 is
attacked queen is coming to h4 the
bishop here is just a monster and after
something like h3 we still play queen h4
and that's it you can't capture because
of checkmate and after you play
something let's say you want to block
the light square bishop we just play
bishop h2 check remove one of the
defenders of the f2 pawn king moves
we're going to capture here with check
rook has to capture because uh if he
doesn't the queen hangs rook captures
queen captures and now it doesn't matter
king captures we're going to capture on
b2 and the white is uh well pretty much
completely busted uh the the king is
wide open we still have a light square
bishop uh we're up upon so also we're up
material this would be very easy game
for rubinstein so instead after bishop
captures on f5 we have f4 now
challenging this bishop and uh now comes
bishop to c7 so while f4 does block the
this diagonal uh it also leaves the e3
pawn very weak and uh
it's not much so here e4 he wants to
advance this pawn all the way to e5 that
will sort of improve his position but
only
only only ever slightly here rook ate
the c8 rubinstein finally completes
development and now comes e5 challenging
the knight here but the problem is you
don't have to
move the knights to any silly squares
because after bishop the b6 check uh
king to h1 now the knight comes to g4
and the queen is the only piece
defending the bishop on d3 so if the
white queen captures on g4 we're just
gonna capture on d3 and uh well we're
gonna have a great position uh and also
if you try to win some material with
bishop captures an h7 king capture some
queen captures on g4 then rogue d2 and
how are you defending this g2 pawn is
hanging once once you defend this you're
going to lose the bishop on b2 so you
can see that black's position is in fact
much much better so here we have bishop
to e4 getting the bishop out of arms
away from the d3 square and also
countering rubenstein's very strong
bishop here but now uh here comes queen
the h4 knight captures on h2 is also
possible and it is in fact the top move
recommended by the engine but it's not
nearly as awesome as the idea that
rubenstein had
and uh uh for a very specific reason
because rubenstein plays queen to h4
he's threatening checkmate with queen
captures on h3 on h2 and there's no good
way to prevent this if you play h3 which
of course is something you can do
we will just remove the defender of the
bishop on e4 rook captures on c3 and now
after bishop captures on c3 we cap run
e4 and now what do you play
there's really not all that much if you
play queen captures on e4 we just play
queen g3 and we are checkmating you now
if you capture the knight this is still
checkmate because the bishop covers the
g1 square so you can't really capture
the bishop here and if you capture the
knight which is the next best thing then
we play queen captures h captures and
now rook to d3 and there's no defense
against it again this bishop
will be lost because if you try to save
the bishop then rook to h3 is checkmate
the bishop covers g1 and this bishop is
pinning the g2 pawn so once you defend
against mate with something like rook to
g1 or or maybe even king to h2 uh then
we're just going to pick up the bishop
we're up material and of course black is
completely winning so after queen to h4
i wrote let me play the g3 makes a
little bit more sense now the queen
guards the h2 pawn and
also the bishop here uh but that's kind
of the thing you can't really have the
queen uh guarded the h2 pawn and the
bishop on e4 because here uh
rubinstein finds a beautiful beautiful
move and i'm pretty sure that he
found this idea when he played queen to
h4 instead of the knight captures an h2
idea and that is rook captures on c3
here rubenstein offers a full queen and
uh
well like i said the the beauty of the
the queen offering is that uh you can't
uh yeah you have to find one very
specific move in order to play it and
you can't decline the queen sacrifice if
you just take the rook bishop captures
here again just bishop captures an e4
and we know that the queen has to keep
an eye on the h2 pawn so rook f3 we have
to give up something then just bishop
captures and f3 queen captures and rook
cap the queen captures an h2 will be
forced so after rook captures on c3 uh g
captures on h4 uh rotlavi accepts the
queen on h4 and now you have to find the
move that wins the game for rubenstein
it is the only move that wins the game
for rubinstein so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this spectacular
idea while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on realizing that
it is uh sometimes not enough to
sacrifice your queen you also have to
sacrifice a rook or two rooks after the
queen like anderson did
but here one rook will suffice and that
is rook to d2 now we offer the the rook
and it all comes with the idea of
removing the the defender of the bishop
on e4
and you can't really ignore this if you
play queen to e1 yes you're still
guarding the bishop but now now comes
rook captures an h2 checkmate so that
rook to d2 was not just uh you know for
sure so here queen captures on d2 was
played and now we have finally bishop
captures on e4 and look at this this is
the one of the most operational bishops
bishop pairs in chess history definitely
there is no way to parry this queen to
g2 was played but now uh you have to be
careful not to butcher your masterpiece
because of course you could capture the
queen and you'd still have a better
position but only a slightly better one
here rubenstein played rook to h3 and he
was in this position animal 25 that
gershwich levy resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
if you do nothing uh then just rook
captures on h2's checkmate because the
queen cannot capture the queen's spin if
you capture the bishop rook captures an
h2 is again checkmate so whatever you
play doesn't really matter rook captures
on h2 will be checkmate so really one of
the greatest chess games ever played and
you know make it even better it was
played with the black pieces uh so uh
both of them played extremely well and
it's it it's no wonder that uh botwinni
considers this game to be uh the first
uh
well sort of the first famous modern
attacking game uh because uh well
players just played incredibly
incredible chess and even this queen to
d2 idea that everyone you know
completely trashed him for uh is uh
seemingly perfectly fine according to
the engine and if you think um okay
around levy he was probably not someone
you know who's pretty good at chess as
you know not a lot of people maybe heard
about him and uh well sort of pretty
much everyone who plays chess uh knows
of akiba rubinstein uh he was he was in
fact incredible uh he uh he played chess
not for a very long time his chess
career was very short uh but he had
tournaments where he tied with with
rubinstein for first place and here is
uh the tournament that he considers his
finest achievement
uh let me just
uh oh sorry uh let me just put this in
perspective so uh we can we can fit
everything
uh so uh it's uh it's a tournament uh
let me just check i don't want to i
don't want to trick you about the year
and everything
uh
let me just check real quickly
yeah it is from the uh determined that
he considers uh his his greatest
achievement the crossbar tournament of
1911 and here you can see that uh he
finished third uh oh sorry fourth uh and
uh winner was uh uh arikart man and
akiba rubenstein in second place tied
with carlos lecter but he won fourth
place in ahead of some incredible
incredible names like uh frank marshall
arno nimsovich and milan vidmar uh paul
landhart savely taktakover aldrich duras
alexander alvin rudel spielmann and the
list goes on so 26 uh well a very very
strong players he was able to uh to win
uh fourth place in this competition so
this only uh shows you how how uh
incredible of an achievement this uh
this victory was for akiba room he
didn't just win this game he also won
the entire tournament uh but uh this
game is uh what everyone remembers for
but uh gershwick levy people would
probably uh hear a lot more about him
and his uh his career would probably go
on for a very long time it would be very
very successful and maybe even lucrative
uh but he suffered uh sort of a
mental disorder and he had to quit
playing chess he couldn't continue and
he uh died very very early on he died in
1920 at the age of 31. 31
and i don't know if i mentioned he was
only 18 years old when he played this
game against rubenstein but yeah this is
rubinstein's immortal game
but it takes you to create an immortal
game
and here you can see what what a
magnificent masterpiece it is uh and
also how how
very well both of them played
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and that you've enjoyed this
little remaster at 60 frames per second
so i hope you hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank will emanuel
said ali ashimi uh alexandra l rushwood
networks and julie mosley for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and maybe
even a brush up on an old video such as
this one uh so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day